[Music]
[Applause]
come on and O'Brien here like to talk
about today there's some things that I'm
really into right now that I thought I'd
talk about on my blog I got tickets for
midnight show of Yogi Bear
I'm totally teen boo boo go boo boo
sometimes I were a Slanket over a
Snuggie and I call it a snake nugget I
invented a new snack called the nine
Musketeers you take three musketeer bar
three of them and you microwave when you
drink it like a smoothie or three by
three is nine you know a lot of people
are giving Miley Cyrus hard time right
now because they you know saw her said
that she smoked some drugs or something
and I just think they're a bunch of
haters Maya's great go Miley in this
next segments called so true Miley so
true my lead
I like to look for inspirational quotes
from Miley on the internet and I found
one Maddy said life is what you make it
and I just want to say so true Miley so
through my lead he gave my room get are
you done yet cuz there's a talk show we
have to do it I'm not doing it by myself
leave me alone any get out of my room
and he's in my room get out get out get
out have peppermint mocha frappuccino
today and I like peppermint but this was
too minty I like it when there's more
moping
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Green is here baby's here